well how did you feel my form fire he
lives his life on fire now if you
thought Will Smith was done celebrating
his 50th birthday after that bungee jump
into the Grand Canyon earlier this week
oh no no think again because Big Willie
just shocked his fans with new music oh
my gasps the prince in my car with the
tents Marc Anthony with the new anthem
yeah no it's a little one to check out
will rapping and singing in Spanish with
Marc Anthony in their sizzling bilingual
video for a tinkle featuring Latin trap
artist bad bunny and sexed-up model Joan
Smalls
giving us major JLo vibes Smith's salsa
send-up dropped last night and got
Twitter fired up we whole mashup rider
when Miami haba he actually got salsa
fied with J Lo's X on a boat in Miami
Harbor back in March and even auditioned
his rap for the Latin superstar a
psyched marked lzt quote will and I have
always wanted to work on a musical
collaboration what took y'all so long
yeah it's been a minute it's been a
minute just over a year ago I was with
Will and his former collaborator DJ
Jazzy Jeff taking the stage in England
and teasing more music to come I got the
bug I was on fire last night I just
can't contain myself on stage what does
that tell you we need to hurry up and do
more shows Marc Anthony D noun 50 year
olds new track caps off a wild week for
will is insane birthday bungee jump into
the Grand Canyon from a helicopter has
now racked up more than 13 million
YouTube views former Fresh Prince
co-star Alfonso Ribeiro tells et quote
it was inspirational to see him what a
day
and we're also there as Alfonso gears up
to celebrate a TV milestone on the set
of America's Funniest Home Videos I
think AFV has been around for 29 seasons
simply because it continues to make
people laugh it's the number one Co
watch show in all of television it's
truly the last of the Mohicans when it
comes to family shows how many videos
have actually played I have no idea do
we know we don't have the exact number
of a well over a million AFV receives on
average 4,500 video submissions per week
and is given away over 15 million
dollars in prize money Alfonzo is the
show's fifth host he's been there since
the beginning in 1989 with then host Bob
Saget you would think that this is an
inexpensive show to make but by showery
seven million dollars and they throw in
a wardrobe that is such a great gig I'm
by the way remember Alfonzo won season
19 of Dancing with the Stars and he
still tight with a lot of the pro
dancers he believes he's a pro dancer
and they even go to his house for
Thanksgiving every year
[Music]
[Applause]